- Let me introduce myself.
I'm Jim Levinsohn,
Director of the Jackson Institute,
soon to be the Yale Jackson
School of Global Affairs.
I'd like to welcome everybody.
Special welcome, we're joined today
by a number of the Ukrainian
students here at Yale.
Our thoughts, prayers.
It's hard for me to imagine
what you are going through
as you are here in New Haven
and dealing with the situation at home.
So thank you for joining us.
I'm joined also by two of
my colleagues up front here,
a number also in the audience.
Let me introduce them.
Arne Westad, Professor of
History and Global Affairs.
Arne has written an amazing book,
"History of the Cold War,"
and has written on and
continues to write on
great power competition.
I'm also to joined by Tim Snyder.
If you have walked by a
bookstore, turned on the radio,
read a newspaper, watched television,
you know who Tim probably,
you probably know who Tim is.
We've had TV crews camped
out on the first floor
of Horchow Hall now for quite some time.
Tim has been working
an incredible schedule.
Very, very grateful that he's here.
What you might not know,
if you've read, you know,
only his most recent work
is that Tim first really,
you know, his earlier work as a historian
before he was a public intellectual
as well as historian was a
book called "Bloodlands,"
which is a history of exactly the area
that we'll be talking about
today in the post Stalin era.
And I'm also joined by Nellie Petlick.
Nellie is a graduate
student here at Jackson.
She spent four years as a Peace
Corps volunteer in Ukraine.
And as we talk through things today,
I thought it was important
not just to think about this
from a historical and
geopolitical perspective,
but to also keep our eye
on the human perspective.
And I hope Nellie might speak to that.
The format today, I wanna
start with a question each
to Arne, to Tim, and then to Nellie.
Possible some follow up,
and then Q&A from you
because there's a lot of
expertise and curiosity
in the audience today.
I'll work my way down.
Arne, let me start with you.
You know, you've spent much of your career
thinking about great power competition.
Wasn't always called that.
Does the current situation
make sense to you
from that perspective?
And with that sort of
geopolitical perspective,
how should we be thinking about this?
- Well, so it depends
obviously on whose perspective
you see this from, Jim.
I mean, I think in Putin's own
mind, it sort of makes sense.
I mean, what he is out to
do is to try to resurrect
some form of Russian
empire, never mind communist,
never mind the Soviet Union.
I think looking at this otherwise
somewhat deranged speech
that he gave at the
start of this conflict,
you can actually understand quite a bit
of what Putin thinks that he's after.
And to him, it is about not
recognizing Ukrainian statehood,
but more importantly,
not recognizing Ukrainian
nationhood, right.
And trying to force Ukrainians
into this new Russian super
state that he wants to set up.
So this is a war of conquest
of a kind that we rarely see,
certainly towards the
end of the 20th century.
There are very few examples of this.
You know, Iraq in Kuwait, perhaps.
So you try to take over
someone else's territory
and make it your own.
On your question of whether it makes sense
in a broader perspective,
and even from a Russian
perspective beyond Putin,
absolutely not.
I mean, what this will lead
to is Russia's isolation.
It will create a Russia that is even more,
much more dependent on China,
which is an angle I
hope we can cover here,
than what has been the case before.
It will, of course also lead to tensions,
not just in Europe, but on a global scale
that we haven't seen for a very long time
because this war is in no way over.
Let me underline that.
I mean, that is really, really important,
not just because the
Ukrainians are fighting
for their country,
but also because of the reactions
that you've seen elsewhere.
I mean how this has brought people,
first and foremost in
Europe, but also elsewhere
together to a degree that we
simply haven't seen before.
And if there is another
sort of piece of information
that people should look at,
it is what happened in the
German Bundestag this past week,
which is a sea change
in terms of how Germany
is approaching its international affairs.
Coming from a social democratic chancellor
and from a green foreign minister, right?
So those are gonna, I
think, gonna be the effects.
So for Russia as a whole,
for the international system
makes no sense whatsoever,
but in Putin's own
increasingly deranged mind, you can see,
where this is coming from.
- [Jim] Tim, what do you think?
I was, I wanna ask you sort of
from the Russian perspective,
you know, what's driving
this, does it make sense?
And then I'd love to hear your
reaction to what Arne said.
- So first of all, I wanna
say, I just wanna acknowledge
the tremendous cognitive inequality
which this meeting represents.
I wouldn't be here as
a historian of Ukraine
if it weren't for historians of Ukraine
who are now in Ukraine, of course,
unable to practice their craft
because they are refugees
or they're in bunkers
or they're in basements
or they're fighting as soldiers.
So if it weren't for my
Ukrainian friends and colleagues
from whom I've learned, if
it weren't for their books,
if it weren't for their language,
I wouldn't be in a position,
I wouldn't have a job at Yale.
I wouldn't be sitting here talking to you.
So I just I wanna acknowledge that
before I say anything else.
And Jim, I hope we have a
second round of questions
before we go to the audience
because I wanna hear you ask
Arne specifically about China
before we do anything else.
That seems to me to be
incredibly important.
So you ask about the Russian perspective,
and as I'm sure, you know,
one of the interesting
things about this war
is that there isn't a Russian perspective.
There isn't even the kind
of artificial euphoria
which was generated back in 2014.
So as all of you know
and many of you will intimately remember
because I see people who
wrote about it and were there,
in 2014, Russia invaded
Ukraine the first time.
In 2014, Russia managed
to occupy and annex Crimea
and attempted with special
forces to provoke rebellions
in eight of the Ukrainian districts,
eight of the Ukrainian
oblasts with partial success
in two of them.
And that partial success had to do
with the successful
provocation of an artillery war
in and around the city of Donetsk in 2014.
So I just remind you of
that because I'm trying to,
I'm trying to set up a certain contrast.
Back then there was a
Russian propaganda build up
to the war.
So in 2013, there was a
sequence of propaganda
targeted for specific audiences.
People on the right were
told that Ukraine was gay
and cosmopolitan, and
people on the far right
were told that Ukraine was Nazi.
And people on the far left
were told that Ukraine was,
sorry, have I got it confused.
People on the far left
were told that people,
that Ukraine was Nazi,
there was a very coordinated
campaign which went on,
and Russia basically won
that information war,
but more, but also the Russian public
was prepared for something
to happen in Ukraine.
And then when it did happen,
when Crimea was seized,
there was this moment of euphoria,
a glorious speech in the
Russian parliament, you know,
parliamentarians in tears, you
know, all that sort of thing.
That we don't have this time around.
There wasn't really a propaganda
preparation, you know,
for this war in Russia.
And Putin's given a series of speeches
in which he seems almost
defensive about what he is doing.
You know, he's even used the phrase,
like it might seem hard
for you to understand.
You know, so when you get
to that point as a dictator,
you know, and you're almost, you know,
you're in this didactic
or even hectoring mode
with your own people,
that's something different
than being in the charismatic mode
where everyone is going along
with you and carrying you
and carrying you along.
So, you know, not to pick on
the question, Jim, but I just,
I think it's important to note that Putin,
the relationship between
Putin and his own people
is quite different than
it was eight years ago.
We don't know exactly what that means yet,
but we do know a couple of things.
One of them is that
right from the beginning,
there were peace protests
in Russia, and every peace,
everyone who protests
for peace in Russia knows
that he or she is going to be
arrested almost immediately.
So the people who actually protest
presumably represent a
very small percentage
of the people who sensed
that something was wrong.
And the sensing that something is wrong
is very important in itself
because as you will all know,
the information is controlled
in Russia very effectively.
So the propaganda might not be working,
but the kind of knowledge
that we take for granted,
you know, on this campus
and in much of the world,
that kind of knowledge is not
easily available in Russia.
So people who protested right
away were people who knew,
just knew that something was
off, that something was wrong.
You know, this war should
not, should not be happening.
The second thing that we
know is that this decision
was taken by a very small group of people.
I mean, by one man, of course,
but I think it was only known
to a very small group of people,
which means that even the Russian elite
has not really had a
chance to adjust to this
or to find a way to rationalize it
or to make plans for their own future
under this regime of sanctions
which has now followed.
So Russian points of
view are much more plural
than they were eight years ago.
And then if,
but if the question is
about how it makes sense
to Mr. Putin, I think Arne
Westad has already signaled
some important things.
It depends, all of this
depends on the assumption
that there isn't really a Ukrainian nation
and there isn't really a Ukrainian state.
I mean, as far, I mean,
Arne may have another idea,
but I mean, as far as I can read it,
the initial operational plan assumed
that the government would quickly collapse
and its members could
be captured and killed
along with the entire
Ukrainian intellectual
and civic and political elite.
The idea was that, you know,
Ukraine's not really a nation.
There's just a thin upper
crust of educated people
who have been somehow
artificially westernized.
So as soon as the tanks
roll in, they'll try to run,
we'll capture them, we'll kill them,
and then the Ukrainians are
a kind of inchoate mass.
They're a kind of undefined group.
They're a precolonial tribe.
They'll just listen to
the stronger, right?
That I think is the governing assumption.
That's a very familiar
governing assumption.
I mean, to any of those
of you who have studied
imperial history or colonial history,
you'll recognize that assumption
that the colonial power says
the other state is not really a state.
The colonial power says the other nation
is not really a nation, right?
And it's interesting to see
people in the, you know,
in the post-colonial world,
like the Kenyan ambassador
for instance to the UN
immediately recognize those patterns.
But that is the fundamental assumption.
And it runs, you know, and as a historian,
it always kind of pains me to
even contest ideas like this
because they're not historical ideas.
Like much as Putin pretends
to talk about history,
these ideas don't come from history.
They come from colonial
reflexes basically.
But so, but I have to contest them.
I just have to make the,
point out the basic problem,
which is that, you know, no
nation and no state is perfect,
but the Ukrainian nation
and the Ukrainian state
are social and political realities
in so far as there are social
and political realities
in the world.
Those things are not really contestable.
And historically speaking,
what's odd is that
you don't even need to get to Maidan 2014
or Invasion 2022 to talk
about the Ukrainian nation.
I mean, it's true
those things have consolidated
the Ukrainian nation,
or they've put the Ukrainian
nation before our eyes
and given us an opportunity to examine it.
But the idea that there's
a Ukrainian nation
is just much older than that.
I mean, the modern
Ukrainian National Movement
goes back 200 years.
And before that there are
actually pre-modern elements
of a Ukrainian nation
far before there are actually
elements of such a nation
in many other places.
I mean, not to make the
point, you know, too strongly,
but the history of Ukraine is much older
than the history of the
United States of America.
However you wish to calculate it.
And so, you know, just looking
at it more practically,
when the Soviet Union was founded,
it was founded in the form it was
because people acknowledged
there was a Ukraine.
You know, the so-called Russian
Civil War between, you know,
let's say 1917 and 1921,
which was a very complicated affair
involving, you know, people supporting
a Russian empire's revival,
people supporting a Ukraine,
people supporting a Russian revolution,
that civil war was
largely fought in Ukraine.
And it was fought by a
number of important people,
some of, you know, some of the politics,
politics was led by someone called Stalin.
And those people recognized at the time
that there was a Ukraine.
They knew they were fighting
against Ukrainian armies,
right, at the time a hundred years ago.
And the Soviet Union was
formed as a union of republics,
as opposed to some kind of, you know,
homogenous, revolutionary unit
because everyone knew at the
time there was a Ukraine.
If you look at the writings, you know,
I'll just like randomly pick some sources.
But if you look at
League of Nations reports
or if you look at the
writings of Joseph Voltz
or like whatever cultural or literary
or statistical analysis, you
kind of prefer from the 1920s,
Ukraine as a category was
widely known to every one.
It wasn't some surprising thing, right?
And so its existence with,
I'm not gonna do all
of Soviet history here.
I'm just trying to make the
point that its existence
was already widely
acknowledged 100 years ago.
And the fact that you would have to fight
to get control of it and
that this was dangerous,
this was known to the Bolsheviks.
It was known to Lenin and Stalin.
And of course it was also
known to a later generation
of Soviet rulers, such as Khrushchev
who was sent to pacify Western Ukraine
at the end of the second World War.
The insurgency and counter
insurgency in Western Ukraine
after the second world war
required hundreds of thousands of deaths
and hundreds of thousands
of sentences to the Gulag
for it to be brought down.
So those are things that like basic
that students of history would know.
And what Mr. Putin has succeeded in doing
is forgetting Soviet history, right?
Arne referred to a kind of Western,
a kind of Russian empire.
I mean,
the kind of Russian empire he has in mind
is a kind of mishmash of all of the things
that he likes from history.
But what he has succeeded in driving away
is actual Soviet history
and at least the practical recognition
that there was such a thing
as the Ukrainian nation,
which at a certain time everybody knew.
What he's managed to do is to
take a kind of extreme version
of the 1970s when he was formed,
a time of Russification
in this Soviet union.
And then as he's aged in
the last decade especially,
he's taken on element of extreme
right Russian nationalism
and pushed these to this
kind of logical conclusion,
which he now seems to have settled on
that there's no Ukrainian
nation and no Ukrainian state.
And of course, that's not true.
And now that it's been
proved not to be true,
it seems like he has no choice,
but to try to, you know,
double down as one does
when one is a tyrant.
And then that leads to the consequences
that Arne was speaking about.
- Thank you, Tim.
Nellie, What are you hearing
from your friends and colleagues?
- Yeah, so just sort
of to add a little bit
about my background since
I think most of you know
these two professors here.
So I was in Ukraine for
four years, as Jim said,
for the first two years
as a Peace Corps volunteer
in a small town in South Central Ukraine,
where I had the
opportunity to meet Oleksii
five years ago at a camp.
And then I decided to stay,
and I started working for Education USA,
which is a network of the state department
that promotes US higher
education opportunities.
And so during that time for
about a year and a half,
I was doing outreach, and I
had the immense opportunity
to travel to 21 out of
24 regions of Ukraine
and really see the
diversity of the country.
Can you hear me okay?
Yes, okay, good.
So I think, you know, as
a Peace Corps volunteer,
I was in a town of 15,000 people.
I was, there was another American there,
but he was working on different projects
in a different part of part o city.
So really I was, you know,
there was nothing special
about my position there.
I was integrating into the
community, learning the language,
treated just as any other teacher.
I was an English teacher at a high school.
So I was at all the staff
meetings and everything like that.
You know, I wasn't treated any
differently as an American.
And so one thing that I
really want to highlight
is the generosity of the Ukrainian people.
It's hard to even talk about.
It's gonna be a long hour guys, sorry.
In our training, when they
were sort of preparing us
to culturally adapt to Ukrainian life,
they talked to us about how
Ukrainians have an outer circle
and an inner circle.
And the outer circle can be
really hard to get through
because Ukrainians and other Slavic people
don't smile at you on
the street, you know,
like we do in America.
And so it might seem
that they're very cold,
but we were told once you
get into that inner circle,
there's nothing else like it,
and you're treated like family.
And I found that to be incredibly true.
And it was a generosity
that I really struggled to
understand and even to accept.
I just didn't, I couldn't
really comprehend
how people could be so generous to someone
that they didn't even know,
especially after all of the horrors
that they have been
through in their history,
as I'm sure Professor
Snyder will talk about.
And I just couldn't believe
that they would be so welcoming
to a stranger because Ukrainians
are the type of people
who give you everything they have,
even when they have nothing left.
And I think we're seeing that right now.
So I would just say sort of
from the human perspective,
I'm really, really glad that
the world is seeing right now
the generosity and the love
and the fierceness to resist
of the Ukrainian people,
and Putin truly, truly
messed with the wrong people.
And I think we're all seeing that.
And in terms of sort of
what I'm hearing and seeing,
Peace Corps volunteers,
Ukraine was the biggest
Peace Corps country
for many, many years.
So returned Peace Corps
volunteers are now mobilizing.
There's a network of about
1,100 of us right now,
working to help, of
course, friends and family
that we still have there,
arrange humanitarian
aid, things like that.
But so much of that is already, of course,
already happening in Ukraine.
I'm in touch with my community there.
And I got a message from
a friend of mine there
about two days ago,
and she said, you know,
in all the chaos and everything,
people are abandoning their pets.
Is there any way that you can help out?
Get us some funds so we can
be buying food and shelters
for these animals.
And so that's what people there
are thinking about right now.
They're mobilizing to help people out.
You know, they're settling
IDPs in my town right now,
even though they themselves are at war.
They're doing everything
they can to help people
who have fled from other
parts of the country.
So I think that's just
what I wanna highlight
is the generosity and the love.
And I'm just really glad
that the rest of the world
is seeing the spirit of
Ukrainians right now.
- Thank you.
Arne, I want to follow up a little bit
on a couple things you said.
There was mention of
this leading to a Russia
that is more dependent on China.
You also spoke, I think the
phrase was tensions in Europe.
It'd be great if you could
follow up on both of those.
In terms of tensions in Europe,
my read is that this has
brought Europe more together,
which I don't, so I was puzzled
by the use of the phrase tensions.
Maybe you could say a
little bit about that,
and then moving forward
with a Russia more dependent on China,
how does that change sort
of how we think about
the global balance of
power such that it is?
- So let me talk about the
China angle to this first
because it is really, really important,
and we don't know yet exactly
how it is going to play out.
What's happening right at the moment
is that the Chinese leaders
are getting increasingly
embarrassed as they should be
with the behavior of their close partner
in trying to destroy Ukraine.
What we need to do is to push even harder
than what we have done
in order to increase
that sense of embarrassment,
of being hurt both directly and indirectly
by what their partners are doing.
It's interesting that
that was not the initial Chinese reaction.
I mean, the initial Chinese
reaction was very clearly
that this was something that would work
to China's advantage
if the Chinese leaders
were able to sit very
still and do very little,
and then the reactions,
the international reactions
against Russia's behavior
would force Russia even
more closely to China
to put it bluntly,
to be exploited more efficiently by China,
the way Russia is already today.
One of the big issues
that you should tell all
of your Russian friends
if you have any, is that Putin's strategy
has led to an almost complete
loss of Russian sovereignty
with regard to China who was
taking advantage of this,
even before the invasion
and attempted occupation
of Ukraine took place,
but now seem to be having
an even better opportunity.
The problem, however, for
the Chinese leadership,
is that what we see now
over television screens
of the behavior that Russian
troops are showing in Ukraine
goes against so much
of what they themselves
have tried to propagate to
the world of Chinese aims.
Ever since the People's Republic
of China was set up in 1949
on the principles of sovereignty,
territorial integrity,
non-intervention, you know,
which the Chinese have been going on about
for a very long time.
So these are the buttons
that we should try to hit.
And I've been trying to hit as well
with the Chinese when I speak to people
in news outlets in China about this.
And I think that sense
that this is problematic,
including to explain to their own people
what is going on is now
increasing in China.
It was very interesting to see today
that they're also starting to prepare
for an economic backlash.
The Asian Infrastructure Investment Bank,
which is in my view
entirely dominated by China
has now stopped issuing loans to Russia.
And the reason why they've done that
is not because the Chinese are moving away
from the Russians diplomatically,
but because of the fear of the effect
of US and Western secondary sanctions,
which could hit that bank,
will hit that bank if they continue
their current lending activities.
So these are the kinds of things
that we ought to think about.
I think it is important
in the kind of situation
that we have now to continue
to speak to the Chinese
about this, even though the answers we get
are not the answers that
we would like to have,
but China is going to be
important with regard to this.
I also think speaking
of the popular level,
I think among ordinary people in China,
in spite of the heavily
censored Chinese media,
there is an increasing concern
about what is happening.
- [Jim] I was gonna ask you about that
because I know you stay in
touch with colleagues there,
speak the language.
- Yeah, I think there is
absolutely no doubt about that.
And it is interesting.
It's interesting,
particularly over the
last three to four days
to see how that has increased,
and that's obviously also
something by, you know,
by publishing in Chinese because
Chinese are smart people.
They find a way around the great firewall
that their regime has
set up to prevent them
from getting information.
So we should do more on that.
Just quickly, Jim, on Europe.
So when I used the term tension,
I meant, first and foremost,
in terms of the relationship
between Russia and the rest of Europe.
That's where, you know,
for a very long time,
very clearly there is going
to be increased tension.
It's true that this has
brought Europe together
to a remarkable degree, but
the question still remains,
and we have to be able to ask ourselves
these tough questions, what should Europe,
which is really at the front
line of this conflict, do?
You know, with regard to
the fighting that goes on
at the moment, and on that as well,
there are different answers.
I am really struck by the degree
to which European neutrals
like Finland and Sweden
have been willing to try to
support Ukraine militarily
in a way that again, only a few weeks ago,
no one would have dreamt
about being possible.
And we're supplying them with weapons
that they actually need
because these are the kinds of weapons
that they have developed
for their own defense,
obviously, thinking ahead about Russia.
I think that's hugely important
because it's gonna spill over
to other European countries as well.
In what to me is the crucial willingness
to resupply Ukrainians who
are fighting for their lives
against this invasion.
I want to underline that.
So there are some people in Europe
and there are some people
here who are saying,
we have to be careful with this
because we do not want to
unleash the third world war.
Now with regard to resupplying
the Ukrainians on the ground
with the kind of weapons
that they actually need
at the moment that is not
risking a third world war.
That is making the risk
of a third world war
significantly lower than
what it would've been
not doing it because it's only
if Putin's regime realizes,
that they get kind of resistance
that we are now seeing
in Ukraine that it will
be possible to push back
in later cases as well.
If we don't do that,
the situation would be
much more dangerous.
So I think it's important to underline
that aspect of it as well.
I was up at, in a prearranged visit
up at West Point yesterday
and spoke to people there about it.
And as many of you will know,
military people tend to be the
most reluctant that we have
to think about actually getting involved
in foreign conflict.
But I wanted to get across
to them that, you know,
resupplying Ukraine in any way that we can
is actually for the,
in a strategic sense, for
the good of this country
and for good of it.
- [Jim] Tim, do you wanna
add anything to that?
- I wanted to say that
I very much appreciated
Nellie's remarks about
her time in Ukraine.
It's, you know, insofar as
we have anything to say,
you know, it's because we've at some point
had someone to talk to
and someone to learn from.
So I very much appreciated that.
I'll just add a maybe couple brief words
about Europe and about Russia.
What I wanted, I mean, going back to
your initial question, Jim,
one thing that I wanted to say,
which I forgot to say, is
that even in the Soviet Union,
Ukraine was governed as Ukraine.
So it was governed at times
with horrible repressiveness,
as for example, during
the first five year plan,
which led to political decisions in Moscow
to allow about 4 million
Ukrainians to die in a famine
who did not have to die.
And that by the way goes
to the question another way
because when you ask, you
know, what is Putin thinking?
He's thinking that none of that is true.
You know, whereas for
Ukrainians, you know,
regardless of whether
the Holodomor comes up
in political conversations or not,
it's a lived family reality.
It's a matter of, you know, grandparents,
great-grandparents, people know it's true,
whether you talk about it or not,
whether it comes up in
international politics or not.
And that, you know, that interpretation
of the Stalin years is one of the things
which marks off Ukrainians from Russians.
You know, people, when
it comes to identity,
everybody wants to make
like these quick jumps,
like it should be about
language, and, you know,
that's like a shortcut,
and it's completely wrong.
And I wish people wouldn't do it.
You know, I mean Arne speaks Mandarin,
but that doesn't, you
know. (Arne laughing)
You know, right?
- Though, I have had people, Tim, in China
asking me which part of China I was from.
- That's good.
- That's never stopped.
- Stopped now, I think.
- That's good.
That's as good as it gets with languages
when people like know, they
think you're from their country,
but they're not sure which part.
That's about as good as it
gets, but you see my point.
I mean, we're all speaking English here,
but I mean, there may not
be anybody in this room
who's from the United
Kingdom, and if, you know,
and if you are, you're
probably too shy to say so,
but so, but people want
there to be a shortcut.
They wanna say like, I wanna
be able to say who you are
because of how you look
or, you know, what you say,
but identity is actually about experience,
about, you know, biographical experience,
your own experience, the
experience of your family,
the experience that you
think you understand,
and the experiences of
Ukrainians, you know,
not just in the last decade,
not just in the last few days,
you know, but in the last
few years with Maidan,
in the last 30 years with
a generation of people
who have grown up in what is a admittedly,
a sometimes cranky and
ramshackle and unpredictable,
but nevertheless, independent state.
You know, people who are,
people who are, you know, 45 and under now
have had the dominant
experiences of their life
in an independent Ukraine,
but it goes back much further than that.
It goes back, the differences
go back hundreds of years.
And I won't bore you with them
because that's what I work on.
And you should always know
that what you yourself work on
is gonna be boring to an
audience, so I won't dwell on it.
But the point though, the point though,
is that when you wanna see the difference
between Russians and
Ukrainians, it's often,
like it's a matter of experience.
And the Stalin period is something that,
what Putin is trying to
literally like, write it out
and flatten it out.
I don't know how many of you pay attention
to these memory laws, but
there's a law in Russia
which says that you're not
allowed to speak about the period
1939 to 1941.
You're quite, and then
right before the invasion,
the criminal penalties
on that particular law
were strengthened and not accidentally
because Putin's behavior
is very much like
Stalin's behavior in 1939.
He's going west.
He's claiming that it's to
rescue endangered compatriots.
He's claiming that he's doing it
because the state to his immediate west
no longer really exists or doesn't exist.
That's pretty much exactly
what Stalin said in 1939
when the Soviet Union invaded Poland.
But my deeper point here is that
what the Russian leadership
is doing is flattening out
a history which is central to the memory,
the lived memory, not a political memory
of people in Ukraine.
And so that's one thing
that I wanted to get to
that there is this Soviet,
there's this Soviet experience,
which was very different for
Ukrainians and for Russians
and is remembered as such,
but that even in the Soviet Union,
no one was denying that
there was a Ukraine.
Like it was governed as a,
it was governed as a Ukraine.
And that's what, as Arne was saying,
that's what makes this proposal
to govern Ukraine as Russia
so radical.
That's never been done ever.
The Russian empire was not
a Russian national state.
It didn't operate according
to national principles.
The people who governed it,
not to put too fine a point
on it, were not Russians.
The elite in the Russian empire
was not ethnically
Russian for the most part.
It was, oh, you look surprised.
It was German and Swedish.
You know, it was Polish.
You know, when the Russian
empire took over Kiev
in the late 17th century,
that was the only institution
of higher education that they had.
So, I mean, there were no,
there was no publishing.
There was no university
in Russia at the time.
But so what I'm trying to say is that like
this notion of Russia
governing Ukraine as Russia
is entirely anachronistic and novel.
It's never happened before.
And so Putin like reaching back
and talking about a thousand years
and all this total nonsense,
Russia wasn't a modern nation then, right?
The Russian empire controlled
much of what is now Ukraine,
but it wasn't governing
it as a national state.
The Soviet Union controlled
what is now Ukraine,
but it wasn't governing
it as a national state.
The idea that a Russian,
a Russia on ethnic principles
can dominate Ukraine
is a really radical idea.
It's the most radical version
of how to govern Ukraine
that's ever been around
except for the Nazi one.
And it's coming at a point in history
where the Ukrainian nation
has been most fully formed.
So I just, I wanted to
bring that particular point
like that to a sharp point.
Thanks.
- Yeah, one last question.
And it's not a very fair
one before we open it up.
You know, Arne, you said
it's important to realize
this is not close to being over.
It's an important point.
I'm wondering if either you or Tim
would to be willing to
hazard a guesstimate,
a prediction as to how this,
I don't wanna say ends
because it will be ongoing,
but how this plays out over
the next six to 12 months.
- I think that goes to
you first. (Arne laughing)
- And as I said, I know
it's not a fair question.
- Well, you also get a slightly
unfair answer to it, Jim.
It won't end until the Russian troops
have withdrawn from Ukraine.
I mean, that's the key element
that it's important to recognize now.
I mean, the idea that it's possible
to get any kind of settlement
that will lead to any form of stability,
even the kind of stability
that Putin wants to impose
in Ukraine without a
withdrawal of Russian troops
is unimaginable.
And we are seeing that now
every day on the streets
of Ukrainian cities.
The big question is of
course how long it will take
before the Russians in charge
realize that that is the case.
And the only answer I have to that
is that that depends on
the degree of pressure,
not just the pressure they get
by a lot of young Russian
people coming back to Russia
in coffins to put it bluntly,
but also the kind of pressure
that we can put on Russia.
So as people up here know,
I've worked very closely
with colleagues in Russia
for quite some time as an historian
because parts of my interest
have been connected to Soviet history.
And of course, I try to
make use of that opportunity
to contact people
while as I was saying
to Tim the other day,
while I was resigning from the
various boards and committees
and various other things that
I found myself on in Russia
also to contact friends and colleagues
and acquaintances directly and tell them
both why I'd done that,
but also what I think the
consequences for Russia will be
of what they have now done.
So I think that's in a
way the timeline here.
So this is also where
China is important, right?
Let me just comment on that very briefly
if I can, Jim, again, because, you know,
this is the first global crisis
where I think that China
potentially has more influence
than this country.
- [Tim] Interesting.
- And so what I and
others are trying to tell
our Chinese friends is
that with great power
comes great responsibility.
You can't simply sit back and do nothing
and hope that the whole
thing will blow over
in a way that will serve you.
You can't do it for domestic reasons,
and you can't do it for
international reasons.
And here some parallels,
imprecise as they might be
from history, but concerning as they are,
need to be put to them.
So one of the perspectives that I now put
to my Chinese friends is the parallel
which I've been discussing
in other context
with the kind of global
situation that we see now
and the situation in Europe
at the end of the 19th
and the beginning of
the 20th century, right?
Where you had this tremendous
growth in German power.
Germany had just been reunified.
It was industrializing.
It was at the forefront of technology.
It was obviously moving towards
and aiming towards a
dominant position in Europe.
Right next to Germany was a ancient
but rather decrepit
empire of Austria Hungary,
which had problems with
a lot of nationalities
inside the empire, but also
along its borders, right?
And for reasons that were
strategic in a very limited sense,
Germany increasingly became
a close ally of that empire.
Even if the Germans knew that
this would lead to trouble.
This, you know, there
would be difficulties
coming out of that.
They couldn't foresee what
happened in the summer of 1914,
but there clearly were difficulties.
This is an imprecise,
but still rather instructive parallel
to the relationship between
China and Russia today.
And it should really be a memento
for the Chinese leaders
to think about this,
that they could end up
in a kind of situation
because of what the Russians are doing
that would really move
China away from the path
that it's on now to even
within its own region
towards further, further influence
for reasons that are not
primarily of Chinese doing
because they are sitting back on this,
but because of their
pseudo-alliance with the Russians.
- [Jim] Tim, do you wanna?
- Yeah, let me have a crack at that
from a different, from a different angle.
I mean, from a great distance, Arne,
I'm also struck by this sort of triangle
of US, China, Russia,
where, it's the Chinese,
it seems to me could turn
this off in a heartbeat
if they wanted to,
but their first reaction is to
put the responsibility on us,
and we actually have much less ability
to do anything about
it one way or another.
There's something very striking
about that juxtaposition,
but on how this comes to an end.
I just wanna stress one dimension of it,
which we haven't really talked about,
which is the dimension of unreality,
the dimension of
propaganda or information,
the dimension of how people
think about all of this,
because, while, of course, you know,
the war in Ukraine is
very realm and, you know,
people are killing and dying
now, you know, and living.
I mean, a treasured
colleague, incredible person
just got married in her bulletproof vest
before this thing started.
Nevertheless, it's also very important
to ask whether reality, you know,
I'm very old fashioned about these things,
I believe in facts and truth and so on.
Whether reality defends
itself against unreality,
because what's been
characteristic of 21st century war
in Russia has been that
the informational character
has run out way ahead of
the kinetic character.
So they've done much
better in the war for minds
than they've done in the war
for territory in general.
And this is a reflection
of an interesting turn
that was taken in Russian
politics in society
in the early 21st century.
Peter Pomerantsev has a
really good book about this
called "Nothing is True,
and Everything is Possible,"
where, you know, when
certain conditions prevail,
extreme inequality of wealth,
centralization of media,
you know, major oligarchical
clan is in charge of the state.
You can govern not by
promising people policy
based on facts that changes the future,
but you can govern by
having the best spectacle
and by crowding out other spectacles
or other sources of information.
And so Russia then has been
fighting wars that way.
And the war in 2014 against Ukraine
was a success in that way.
It wasn't actually a battlefield
success particularly.
It went less well for
them than they expected
on the battlefield,
but they did a very good job
with Western public opinion.
And they did a very good job
with American public opinion.
They managed to prevent
American and European elites
from seeing the basic things
that were happening, right?
It's still hard.
People still feel a kind
of internal resistance
to saying Russia invaded Ukraine in 2014,
although that's the most,
you know, that's the
simplest most lapidarian,
most accurate characterization
of what happened.
There are all kinds of
pre-programmed reflexes
that people have instead of that,
even though that's, you know,
that's the most important
thing that happened.
For this war, it has gone
less well for Russia.
People learned a lot in
the last eight years.
Ukrainians learned a lot.
It's, the Ukrainians
have done a very good job
at expressing themselves as themselves.
So not trying to take up the cudgels
and fight a Russian style information war,
but rather do creative,
interesting things,
you know, to try, just to make
it clear that they're real,
and they have a character.
Even their propaganda
directed against the Russians
is often very interesting
or even has a kind of almost
humanitarian tone to it.
So the Ukrainians have done a better job,
but the larger, but the
larger issue here is reality.
You know, can we talk to Russians
and just help them
understand what's going on
without brow beating them?
You know, can we get to our
Russian friends and colleagues
or their colleagues or our Russian cousins
and their cousins, and just
communicate a little bit?
Is the west going to do a better job
at talking about what's actually going on?
Which doesn't mean
making better propaganda?
I don't think we win
with better propaganda.
I don't think, you know,
I don't think that's really our job,
but can reality as such
hold back unreality.
That's a big, so if this
thing only comes to a close,
if we continue to keep a grip
on what's actually happening
on the battlefield.
That's a big part of it.
If we drift off into
propaganda stereotypes
or wishful thinking, you know,
or we spend our time
talking about the concepts
that Mr. Putin wants us to talk about.
You know, then this goes on, right?
So I just, I think it can, I mean,
I don't wanna dodge the question, Jim.
I do think this can end.
I mean, I can imagine an
arrangement whereby this would end,
but like everything else,
it depends like, you know,
like everything else, like
this conversation itself,
it depends upon the Ukrainians
continuing to fight, right?
I mean, imagine a world
in which the Ukrainians hadn't fought.
It's a very different world, right?
But if the Ukrainians hadn't fought,
we would not be thinking about
all the things we're
thinking right now, right?
If the Ukrainians hadn't fought
that wouldn't make Putin a better dictator
or the Russian system, a better system.
We just wouldn't be thinking
about it in the same way.
If the Ukrainians hadn't fought, you know,
people around the world
wouldn't have chance
to think about what they, you know,
to think about what colonization
and decolonization mean,
or to think about what democracy
and oligarchy mean, right?
They've given us this chance,
including the chance to
have the conversation
that we're having right now,
but for there to be some
kind of a settlement,
I mean, there's, Arne's already
mentioned all the parts.
The Ukrainians have to keep fighting.
People have to keep helping them.
There has to be a conversation,
if that's the word,
among Russian elites.
There has to be resistance
on the part of the Russian population,
and big powers like China and
America have to keep nudging
and suggesting possible ways out.
- Can I add something on that?
- [Jim] Please, please.
- So I just wanted to add that even after,
so I've been in the prediction
business for a couple years,
so I won't speak to speak to that part,
but even after the Russian
troops withdraw from Ukraine,
this will not be over for Ukrainians
for a very, very long time.
So I'm so glad to see so
many people here today.
We maxed out the attendance.
And so I want to ask you to
resist the urge to disengage
because even in a week,
I've seen a big difference in the way,
I have the "New York Times"
sort of live stream updates
on my computer, and I've
seen a big difference
in the way that they're covering things,
even within a week.
And I also forgot to mention,
as part of my background,
I've been working with
the state department
for about nine months now,
tracking Russian disinformation efforts
and synthesizing those
for government partners.
So I have some background
there and can speak to that
and can say that they're
actively right now
pushing narratives and pushing efforts
to try to get Western allies
to disengage from this issue.
So just something to keep
in mind as this goes on,
that's true for so many
tragedies and conflicts
that happen around the world.
It inevitably happens, but you know,
there's been a hot war
raging in Eastern Ukraine
for eight years, and the
west disengaged from it,
really stopped covering it.
And it's part of the reason
that we're here today.
So just something to keep in mind.
- Nellie, thanks.
I'd like to open it up
with the remaining time
for a few questions.
Jimmy Hatch.
- Hey, I'm a veteran and I served
in a bunch of different
conflicts in the past
in our history,
and this reminds me particularly
of the former Yugoslavia.
And while I'm not culturally
aware of the Ukrainians,
their history,
I do think that there's the opportunity
for what happened in the former Yugoslavia
when the people who did
the bad things there,
who created the mass graves,
they've concentrated everybody's
attention on Sarajevo.
And during that time
they were doing things
in the other part of the country.
And I'm worried that that,
for example, this morning,
when I saw the news about the
nuclear planet being shelled,
what do they not want us to see?
And what do you think, how do you think
that they'll keep our attention focused
and do something in a
different part of the country?
What do we need to be looking for there?
- Thank you.
Are we doing this one by one or?
- Yeah.
- No, I think that's a
very apt observation.
I mean, the Russians are
not on their best game
with the propaganda
and the provocation yet
because I believe their understanding,
their expectation was that
Ukraine was gonna fold
within 24 hours.
And that, we think that
not just because of how,
of how they set up, quote unquote,
the first stage of the operation,
but also because of some things
that were accidentally
published in the Russian press,
which basically, they
accidentally published
some of their victory declarations,
which if you haven't seen
them are absolutely chilling
because they basically speak of a,
of what, you know, what Raphael
Lemkin called the genocide
in which the nation has been decapitated,
and everyone else just has
no choice but to go along,
and Ukraine has essentially
ceased to exist.
So they're not on, they're not,
in terms of provocation and
ideology and disinformation,
I think it's only going to get stronger
as I think maybe Nellie was suggesting
as they try to, 'cause they
went in doing one thing.
That didn't work, and now
they're still, I think,
trying to figure out how
they're gonna talk about
what they're doing,
and whether it's hard
for them to talk about it
'cause they're not really sure themselves.
It's Putin doubling down,
and they have to win,
but what winning means, they don't know.
And of course, I agree with
Arne, like it's gonna be,
I don't think they're gonna win ever.
But you know, the question is whether,
the question is whether
there's some kind of
acceptable solution in
months, you know, or whether,
or whether it's like
Afghanistan plus for them
in years and horror for the Ukrainians.
But I mean, what I think is real
is the attempt to assassinate
the Ukrainian leadership,
and that's something which is
difficult to keep your eye on.
But I think important not to forget about.
And I don't think the Russians
have forgotten about it.
That this war was about
decapitation, announced as such
pretty much, pretty explicitly.
We should probably, you
know, probably remember that.
And if Ukrainian leaders,
you know, disappear
or whatever it might be,
there's a pretty strong
presumption about what might,
what is in fact happening.
You know, and that, I
mean, that Putin's concept
is that Ukraine doesn't exist.
There are just a few thousand,
you know, artificial,
like when those people start
disappearing, you know,
we can, I mean, that's just
a horrible thing to say,
but that plan has already, has
essentially been announced.
- [Jim] Please, and do
you need the microphone?
- [Woman] Yes.
- [Jim] So that the live,
the streaming can catch it.
- First, I want say thank you
to the panelists and everyone
for coming out.
It's been really
instructive and eye opening
to kind of hear your perspectives,
and I'm very appreciate
as just like a passive American
observer of what's going on.
I have seen sort of several
narratives put forth
in the last week
that perhaps some of what is
motivating Russia right now
to kind of get themselves into this mess
beyond just sort of the
ideological state defining stuff
is actually like sort of maybe
also a battle over resources,
specifically oil and natural gas,
with the natural gas
found in the Black Sea.
But just prior to the 2014 invasion,
which Russia control Crimea now,
that that would be the main way
that Ukraine could have exploited
those natural gas resources,
but then there's still
some that are available
from Odessa and other ports
that Ukraine still
controls in the Black Sea.
And I was, and I guess, so
if Ukraine were to exploit
these natural gas resources
and become the new Eastern
European petrol state,
which theoretically could
threaten the Russian economy,
which is primarily based on the
exploitation of fossil fuels
and the sale of them to
the European continent.
I was just wondering if you experts
think there's any validity to that theory
or if it's sort of maybe
sideshow distraction or yeah.
Just anything you might speak
about that sort of energy
and resource side of things.
Thank you.
- So I don't think that's
one of the key reasons
why Putin has acted the way he has.
We know again from some
of these leaked documents
that Tim referred to that
in part of how this is being presented,
was supposed to be presented after victory
from the Russian side, then the idea was
that this would strengthen
this new cohesion
that had been created
around Russia economically
also with regard to access to resources,
which then in Putin's telling,
the west was trying to cut off
in order to strangle Russia.
I mean entire nonsense, of
course, with regard to it.
But so I don't think that's
what we should be looking at
most closely.
I think the, as Tim has been saying,
the central idea here is about
the attempted destruction
of Ukrainian nationhood.
And that is a story that
is first and foremost
Putin's story about Russia
and about the kind of Russia
that he wants to see
projected into the future.
And this is where some of the
dissonance comes up as well.
I mean, I do think that is actually quite,
quite important to note here.
And I really appreciated what Tim said
about this being a very
novel way of thinking about
how to rule, how to rule Ukraine.
I hadn't given enough thought to that.
And I think that's a
really, really good point,
but it also is a way of
thinking that it seems to me
is outta whack with almost
everything that is happening
elsewhere in the world.
And getting back to the
Chinese and Asian side,
this is the kind of thing that
I think is really difficult
for their elites to
get their heads around.
I mean, they don't like
us very much necessarily.
They don't like the way the
United States is governed
or the way Europe is governed
or anything of that sort.
But there is still a, in
terms of conversations
and in terms of discussions,
as some of my Chinese friends like to say,
we do speak the same language, right?
In terms of the things that matter
and the things that matter less.
In terms of Putin's Russian elite,
that is not the case.
I mean, there is a kind of discourse
that seem to be entirely internal
to that particular elite
and on the issue of resources, you know,
I think in most other settings
with this kind of effort being put into
taking over another country
that would have ranked
fairly highly up, you know,
on the agenda.
It doesn't in the Russian case.
And the reason for that
is that the discourse is different, right,
from of what you find
in many other settings.
At least that would be my response to it.
- Yeah, I mean, American and
Russia are very different.
But if you think back to the
US invasion of Iraq in 2003,
anybody looking out of the
distance would've said,
oh yeah, isn't that about the oil fields,
but somehow it wasn't even
about the oil fields, right?
It was about views about the world
and how the world was gonna
change after a war and so on,
which were entirely wrong, you know,
just as these ideas are entirely wrong.
I just wanted to, I wanted to, I agree,
complete with what Arne said.
I wanted though to tack onto your question
a kind of larger
observation, which is that
the 21st century is a century
of hydrocarbon oligarchy
and getting to the 22nd century
is gonna be a matter of breaking
up hydrocarbon oligarchy
foreign and domestic,
and this entire war wouldn't be possible
without the way that the
Russian state is constructed
as a hydrocarbon oligarchy.
And, you know, I mean, of course,
day to day, month to month,
what we need to be thinking
about are the Ukrainians
and supplying the Ukrainians.
But this is, this whole war
is actually actually one
more piece of evidence
that we need to shift to clean
and safe sources of energy.
That's so this isn't a distraction.
I mean, we shouldn't be thinking of this
as a distraction from climate change.
This would be like one more reason why
we need to be shifting over to
different sources of energy.
- So I'm mindful of the time,
and I'm mindful of the fact
that we're holding this
at a day and time where classes
actually are in session.
So with some regret, I'm
gonna call it to a close.
We could talk for a long, long time.
And as Nellie said, I hope we will be.
I'd like to thank the panelists
for their time this morning.
And most of all, I'd
like to thank all of you
for taking time out of your day,
showing the concern that's
evidenced by your being here
on a Friday morning.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
(gentle music)